- "Dungeons & Dragons"
has altered the deal.
Pray they do not alter it any further
because for years Wizards of the Coast,
which publishes "Dungeons & Dragons"
has operated under an open
gaming license, an OGL
that allowed people
to create and profit
from unofficial content
in the "Dungeons & Dragons" universe.
Or does it?
It's time to think like a rules lawyer.
The idea is that the OGL
is a legal framework that allows people
to use the rules and ideas
of the role-playing games
to create their own works.
And it was originally
released in the year 2000
by Wizards of the Coast.
And a lot of people
have come to rely on the terms of the OGL
to make and publish their own content
under the aegis of Wizards of the Coast.
But that was version 1 of the OGL,
now, according to a leaked
version 1.1 of the OGL,
which has not officially been adopted,
makes huge sweeping changes
that will affect anyone that makes content
even related to "Dungeons & Dragons."
But this leaked version
1.1 update to the OGL
is a mixed bag.
It purports to crack down
on sexist, homophobic
and transphobic content
that is created with the
"Dungeons & Dragons" name.
It purports to grant a perpetual license
to Wizards of the Coast
for anyone that makes
content using that license.
It purports to require certain people
who make content using that license,
to report that usage
to Wizards of the Coast
and if you make over $750,000 in revenue,
you have to pay certain
royalties up to 25%
to Wizards of the Coast on
certain marginal income.
These are big changes.
Now it's important to distinguish the OGL
from the actual "Dungeon & Dragons" rules.
The "Dungeons & Dragons"
operates under a set of rules
that's up to version 5e at this point,
and the OGL is not the
"Dungeons & Dragons" rules.
And generally speaking,
those rules are found
in the Systems Reference
Document, the SRD.
That's a 400 page document
containing just about
everything you need to know
about playing "D&D".
The main benefit of the OGL,
whether you're talking about
version 1 or version 1.1,
is that it allows people to
use and reproduce the SRD,
the rules.
But for people who make content
that just simply works with the rules
but doesn't reproduce them,
well there's a big question
about whether you need the OGL at all.
Now, we'll come back to that later.
Now, these sweeping changes
caused a huge uproar
among fans and content creators alike.
But like I said, it's a mixed bag.
On the plus side, it provides
a relatively clear path
to allow almost anyone to create
officially licensed content,
and that's pretty rare.
It's not like Disney says,
"Sure, you can make any
Mickey Mouse content you want.
Just pay us if you happen to
make over $750,000 in revenue."
And if these changes were coming
from a position of absolute restriction,
like Disney has a lockdown on their IP,
then people would probably rejoice
that they have this pathway
to make officially licensed
content and profit from it.
But as it stands, we're
coming from the opposite.
We're coming from a world
where almost everything was totally open
and these restrictions are
causing a lot of consternation,
so many people are upset about
this leaked modified OGL.
And the leaked OGL differentiates
between commercial and
non-commercial content.
People making non-commercial
content are fairly unburdened.
And the leak says that
making money via Patreon
doesn't necessarily count as commercial,
so that probably covers
a large swath of people
who might otherwise be
upset about these changes.
Now, I'm not gonna dive too deep
into the changes of this OGL.
It's reasonably easy to understand
to the credit of the
lawyers who drafted it,
and a lot of the coverage
has already described
what the implication of
these purported changes are.
And there are some issues
as far as enforceability,
and promissory estoppel, and reliance.
Can you revoke a license that
was granted in perpetuity?
I'm not gonna get into those.
For a more detailed breakdown
of the contractual provisions themselves
I'd highly recommend
you check out the nerds
over at "Opening Arguments."
They really go into the details
of what the original
and the leaked OGL say,
and what they don't say.
It's absolutely the best breakdown
of the contracts themselves.
But I also think
almost everyone is
missing the biggest issue.
And what I want to cover today
is one of the more fundamental
flaws with this whole setup,
and I think, frankly,
it changes everything.
And as it happens, this whole controversy
is a perfect opportunity to teach people
about the difference between
copyright and trademarks,
so you know, (laughs) win-win.
But the original OGL has
been around for a while
and it was intended to provide
an open platform for players,
and for some of the critical
background on that history
I turn to the "D&D" expert
and ubernerd, Matt Colville.
- The products that they
make for "Dungeons & Dragons"
tend to sell best to players.
Well, adventures don't make a lot of money
because only one of the four
or five players at the table
buy them, but you still gotta make 'em.
So his argument was, "Why
don't we open these rules
and make it so that people,
anybody can make products for us?
And that way third party
companies will come along
and they will make adventures for us,
and they'll make other stuff
too, but we don't care,
and that way they'll support our product."
And there was also some
verbiage in there about how,
"And if those companies improve our rules
and it's published under the OGL,
then we can take those
improvements, right?
And then our game will improve."
And that was a, you know,
a very egalitarian way
of looking at things.
And then fast forward
and Wizards of the Coast
releases a 4th edition
which was very controversial
and alienated a lot of fans.
And so they sort of freaked out
and released a 5th edition.
4th edition wasn't released
under the Open Gaming License,
it was released under a
different license called the GSL
which was much more
draconic and restrictive.
And then 5th edition was
released under the old OGL,
which was much more open and broad,
and empowers people to
make the stuff they want.
Privately, the reason Ryan said
he wanted to talk the
board into opening "D&D"
was because he did not like the idea
that any one company
would control this hobby.
Like he was like, "I don't think,
I think "D&D" should belong to everybody
and this is the best
thing way I can think of
to make that happen."
"D&D" is, I think, more of
a folk tradition and a hobby
than it is a classical brand.
And it has always relied
on the people who play it,
more so than any other game I can think of
except, you know, perhaps
like "Skyrim," right?
Where there's so many mods for it.
It's always relied on the
audience to create content for it.
Things like the Thief
come from people playing
in Los Angeles and coming,
a new class of literally calling
up Gary Gygax on the phone
and saying, "Hey, we got this cool idea."
And he was like, "Oh, that's cool.
I'd probably do it like this."
And all of a sudden there's
a thief in the game, right?
So that relationship
between the players and
the people making the game
has always been a lot more
gray and weirdly nuanced
than almost any other game I can think of.
- Okay, so with that
background out of the way,
let's talk about the difference
between copyright and trademark.
I promise it will be worth it.
Now, copyright is a certain
legal protection for expression.
When you have an original
work of authorship,
whether it is a movie or a novel
and you affix it to a tangible medium,
well then copyright will
protect that expression.
Copyright does not protect ideas,
it does not protect processes,
it protects expression,
whether that expression
is in the form of words,
or a painting, or a video,
copyright will provide
quite a lot of protection.
Trademark is about serving to identify
the source of a particular
product or service
to distinguish that product
from other sellers in the marketplace.
The idea with trademark
is you don't want consumers confused.
You want people to actually
know what they're buying
at the time of sale.
And trademark is a little bit different
and it can last forever.
As long as someone is actually
selling the trademark good,
that trademark will continue
for the protection of consumers.
Now, "Dungeons & Dragons"
as a tabletop RPG product
involves both.
It contains copyrightable
pieces of expression
as well as trademarkable elements
that are meant to identify
it in the marketplace.
Let's use a board game that
everyone is familiar with,
"Monopoly" as an example here.
The name "Monopoly" is trademarked.
There is a long history of
the "Monopoly" trademark
that dealt with years
and years of litigation.
Let's put it aside for the moment.
The logo of "Monopoly"
is also trademarked.
The official "Monopoly" board,
the actual squares and everything
on it, that's copyrighted,
that is expression, it's
as if it were a painting.
And then sometimes within board games
you have specifically detailed characters
that can be copyrighted.
For example, in "Monopoly"
rich Uncle Pennybags is
a copyrighted character.
And in "Clue" you have Colonel Mustard,
those are copyrighted characters.
- I'm a real guest.
(fanfare trumpet music)
- But the name of the game
"Monopoly" is trademarked
so you can't go out there
and create a game called
"Monopoly" and sell it,
even if the rules of the game
are completely different.
But what about the opposite?
What if you created a game
that had a different name
but followed the same
rules as another game?
Well, that takes us to
the fundamental flaw
of this whole entire controversy,
which is that you can't
copyright the rules to a game.
You can't copyright a process.
Now this goes back
to an extremely old
copyright Supreme Court case
in the late 19th century
called Baker versus Selden
where someone tried to copyright
a particular method of bookkeeping.
In that case, a guy created
a method of bookkeeping,
i.e accounting and
published a book about it.
The book did okay, but it really took off
when another person created another book
of basically just forms that
used the same methodology
but didn't credit the original person.
The original author sued,
but the Supreme Court said
that there was no copyright available
because you can't copyright a method.
And that idea was later codified
in the Copyright Act of
1976, which said, quote,
"In no case does copyright protection
for an original work of authorship
extend to any idea
procedure, process, system,
method of operation, concept,
principle, or discovery,
regardless of the form
in which it is described,
explained, illustrated,
or embodied in such work."
So, for example,
if you wondered why
everyone could play the game
"Words with Friends" on Facebook,
even though it was an
exact clone of "Scrabble",
well that's the reason.
"Scrabble" can't have copyright protection
over the rules of the game,
it can only really get
trademark protection
over the name "Scrabble" not
the rules contained therein.
Now, there is a little
bit of a wrinkle here
in the sense that if you
had a manual of rules,
you do get a thin copyright
over the exact expression over the rules
as laid out in that rule book.
However, you don't get a copyright
over the rules and processes themselves.
So in a sense, you can have something
that has exactly the same
mechanics, the same processes,
it just can't necessarily
have the exact same expression
if you were to reproduce
the rules perfectly,
but that's kind of a minor quibble.
So how does this relate
to the Wizards of the
Coast update to the OGL?
Well, I think, and I could be wrong,
that Wizards of the Coast is assuming
that anytime anyone creates any content
that happens to use the
rules of "Dungeons & Dragons"
that it's covered by the OGL.
I don't think that's the case.
Now, this is not legal
advice. Your mileage may vary.
But as we discussed you
can't copyright the rules,
you can't copyright the
methodology and processes
and that takes us to the thing
that no one is talking about.
Here's part of the secret,
the original OGL kind of
sucks, and here's why.
The main benefit of the OGL
was that it allowed
people to include the SRD,
the System Reference
Document in their material.
If your material doesn't require
a reprinting or quoting of
the SRD or the 5e rules,
then you probably don't need the OGL.
The original OGL allowed
people to use what it called,
quote, "Open Game Content"
meaning, quote, "The game
mechanic and includes the methods,
procedures, processes, and routines
to the extent such content does not embody
the product identity."
Now, it did not allow people to use,
quote, "Product Identity" meaning, quote,
"Product and product line names, logos,
identifying marks including
trade dress; artifacts;
creatures characteristics;
stories, storylines, plots,
thematic elements, dialogue,
incidents, language, artwork,
symbols, designs," et
cetera, et cetera, et cetera.
So based on what we've
already discussed here,
I'm not sure that there was much benefit
to the original OGL.
It mainly allowed you
to use stuff that you were
already allowed to use,
unless you wanted to
actually quote the expression
that was found in the SRD itself.
And the new OGL does
basically the same thing.
The leaked OGL allows licensed people
to use, quote, "Licensed content."
It says, "Usable D&D content",
quote, "'Licensed content.'
This is Dungeons & Dragons content
that is included in the SRD version 5.1,
including basic game mechanics,
a curated selection of
classes, monsters spells,
and items that allow you to make content
compatible with Dungeons
& Dragons 5th edition."
And then the new OGL goes on to say,
"Not usable D&D content"
quote, "'Unlicensed content.'
This is Dungeons & Dragons content
that has been or later will
be produced as official,
that is released by Wizards of the Coast
or any of its predecessors or successors,
and is not present in the SRD version 5.1.
Unlicensed content includes things
like the most famous Dungeons & Dragons
monsters, characters, magic spells,
and things related to the various settings
used in Dungeons & Dragons
official content over the years,
what the old open license
content referred to as", quote,
"Product identity."
So both OGLs purported to let you use
game mechanics of "Dungeons & Dragons".
And in my view,
that's stuff that everyone
was always allowed to use.
But of course the benefit of the OGLs,
whether it's version 1 or version 1.1
is that it provides
certainty, so there's that.
But let's differentiate
between two different types of content.
In one bucket you'll have what I'll call
reproduction content.
And in the other bucket
you have what I would call
homebrew content.
In this first reproduction bucket
you have things that would
probably be considered,
from a copyright perspective,
derivative works.
That is works that are based
on a copyrighted property
that Wizards of the Coast owns.
So for example, if you made a T-shirt
that features a character that is based on
an official Wizards of the Coast
"Dungeons & Dragons" campaign,
and you put that on a T-shirt,
even if you paint it yourself
well that's probably a derivative work
and you need to get the permission
of Wizards of the Coast.
And to their credit,
Wizards of the Coast has a fan art policy
that allows fans to create fan art.
And this is on their website,
and I don't think it's changed.
But also in this bucket is
stuff that reproduces the SRD.
Remember I said that
they do have a copyright
over the actual exact
wording that's in the SRD,
and recall that both the
original OGL and version 1.1
allow people to reproduce the SRD.
So if your livelihood
relies on actually reproducing
the expression of the SRD,
you would need to abide
by the terms of the OGL,
and I don't think that has changed.
And maybe you want to quote
large sections of the SRD
to put it into a reference manual,
or maybe you want to put
the entire SRD into a PDF
along with your original content,
say if you created an
entirely new set of rules,
but it starts with a basis of the SRD
and you don't want to have people
referencing back to the old SRD.
Well that is probably covered.
And to their credit,
both versions of the OGL
allows people to do that,
if you want to quote the SRD
it creates a pathway for that.
But this reproductive
bucket consists of things
that are based on things
that Wizards of the Coast
can actually copyright.
In the second bucket,
and this is the thing
that I think most people are upset about,
would be homebrewed
adventures and campaigns
whose only connection
to Wizards of the Coast
is the fact that they use the rules
in "Dungeons & Dragons 5e."
In this bucket I'm kind of
thinking about the things
that you see see on "Critical
Role" or "Dimension 20"
where they create a campaign
that is 100% original.
The characters are completely new,
the settings are completely new
and the only connection
that these campaigns have
to "Dungeons & Dragons"
and Wizards of the Coast
is that they rely on the
rules that are set out
in "Dungeons & Dragons 5e."
As we discussed, I don't
think Wizards of the Coast
has much protection over
the rules themselves,
the processes and methodologies
contained in the "Dungeons
& Dragons" rules.
So if you create an
otherwise original campaign
where the only connection
is the fact that it uses
the rules that are set out in "D&D 5e",
I don't think that runs afoul of the OGL.
In fact, I don't think you need permission
from Wizards of the Coast in any case.
Even if you videotape and
livestream that campaign,
I don't think you need their permission
because at the end of the day,
Wizards of the Coast doesn't really have
any kind of IP protection
over the rules themselves.
Now admittedly, there's
a lot of gray area here
because it's not as simple
as one bucket for fan art
and one bucket for homebrew.
Wizards of the Coast and "D&D"
has all kinds of different characters.
Some are pre-made.
Now arguably, those characters
are often in the service of
the mechanics of the game.
They define the strength
or speed or dexterity
of these particular characters,
but there's also a backstory there.
So does that create the kind
of character that is protected,
like Colonel Mustard or James Bond,
or is that simply a rule in the game
that functions within
that rule-based universe?
That's a tough question.
But I'm also skeptical
that the changes to the OGL
affect virtual tabletops
or Kickstarters, as well.
Again, the virtual tabletops
are basically using the mechanics
of the rules themselves,
which I don't think Wizards of the Coast
has much protection over.
And same with Kickstarters
over original campaigns and adventures.
You know, again, if you're creating
an entirely original world
that just simply happens to use
the rules of "Dungeons & Dragons",
I'm not sure that there's
much that Wizards of the Coast
can do about that.
Though, at the same time,
if you are trying to do a Kickstarter
over something that Wizards of the Coast
actually has protection over,
if you wanted to crowdsource a movie
based on the mythos and
lore of "Dungeons & Dragons"
that probably is going
to be covered by the OGL.
Though another gray area
where I'm not sure where
a court would come down
would be, say,
live-streaming a play-through
of an official Wizards of the Coast
"Dungeons & Dragons" campaign.
Obviously Wizards of the Coast publishes
a number of official "Dungeons
& Dragons" campaigns,
and if you live-streamed
you and your friends
playing through that,
that is using official
"Dungeons & Dragons" content
over which they do have the copyright.
That's a tough call.
Though I would say that's analogous
to live-streaming a
play-through of a video game,
which is also kind of a gray area.
A video game is copyrighted.
And it's an open question
whether your playing-through it
is adding enough original content
to be covered by fair use.
And the same would go for playing-through
a "Dungeons & Dragons" official campaign.
Though I do think that
is a separate question
from the, kind of, fully original
homebrew type of situation that
we were just talking about.
Now, if you are a big player in the space,
like "Critical Role" or "Dimension 20"
there might be some true advantages
to making sure that everything
is officially licensed
by Wizards of the Coast,
and they might not be able to avoid it.
And certainly if you are
going to create your homebrews
that are not officially licensed,
you can't say that they
are officially licensed
and you probably can't use
the name "Dungeons & Dragons"
except in a nominative or
descriptive fair use way
in the sense that you might
be able to say something like,
"This campaign is compatible
with 'Dungeons & Dragons.'"
Because even with trademark restrictions,
you can describe a thing
by its official name
but you're likely to be
able to compare stuff
and say that this is compatible
with the rules of "Dungeons & Dragons",
you're just not allowed to say
that this is from "Dungeons & Dragons"
or somehow officially licensed.
Anyway, that's just a theory.
A game, legal theory.
And of course the
situation has now changed.
Wizards of the Coast released a statement
on dndbeyond.com on January 13th.
In a tongue-in-cheek way, they
said that they were cognizant
of all of the pushback
and, quote, "Rolled a one."
They say that, quote,
"The next OGL will contain the provisions
that allow us to protect and cultivate
the inclusive environment
we're trying to build
and specify that it covers
only content for TTRPGs.
That means that other expressions
such as educational and charitable
campaigns, live-streams,
cosplay, VTT-uses, et cetera,
will remain unaffected by any OGL update.
Content already released
under version 1.0a
will also remain unaffected.
What it will not contain
is any royalty structure.
It also will not include
the license back provision
that some people were afraid
was a means for us to steal work.
That thought never crossed our minds.
Under any new OGL
you will own the content you create.
We won't.
Any language we put down
will be crystal clear
and unequivocal on that point."
Now, not only have I been talking
to tons of "D&D" players and GM's,
I've also been talking to
Wizards of the Coast's lawyers.
Now there's tons of stuff
going on behind the scenes,
but all the lawyers will officially say
is that their statement is sincere.
Typical lawyers. Just the worst.
But look, it's great that they
listened to the criticism.
I'm sure that the changes will mollify
a lot of what people are
currently upset about.
But I think the point remains,
if you're only making content
that is "D&D" compatible
and doesn't reproduce their IP,
well maybe you never needed
to comply with the OGL
in the first place.
Maybe the real OGL
was the friends that
we made along the way.
(bright music)
Smoke bomb.
(explosion booming)
Now, normally I would not
cover a topic like this.
This is way too nerdy even for me
and it's way too in the weeds.
Normally a subject like this
would be covered by a fellow
YouTube attorney, Richard Hoeg.
A few days after Christmas,
he suffered a stroke,
was rushed to the hospital,
and underwent extensive brain surgery.
It seems like he's
through the worst of it,
but regardless, he's going to have
an extensive recovery period.
And Richard has always
been a straight shooter,
and his YouTube channel, Hoeg Law,
has always been a resource for
insightful legal commentary
on a lot of legal minutiae.
And his channel, as many of you know,
is focused on the gaming
and video game industry.
Things that Richard is
incredibly passionate about.
This is exactly the kind of video
that he would've loved to have
made if he'd been able to.
His road to recovery is going to be long.
His sister has created a GoFundMe page
called Reasonable Minds Can Rebuild,
because one of Richard's famous phrases
is that reasonable minds can differ,
because he wasn't afraid to
offer an unpopular opinion
because reasonable minds can differ
especially when it comes to the law.
And that's always been an
incredibly admirable trait of his.
So I put a link to his GoFundMe page
down in the description and up on screen.
If you're able to support it,
it would mean the world to me
so that we can speed along his recovery
because legal commentary on YouTube
is just a little bit dimmer
without his contributions.
And then of course,
he can deal with all these
frigging nerdy questions
about "Dungeons & Dragons"
and Wizards of the Coast.
Bunch of nerds.
(explosion booming)
Cool kids play "Magic."